[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Although
this kid is smiling,
he is actually hard at
work pouring molten metal
in a shipyard in Dhaka.
Not exactly an ideal
environment for a child.
Sometimes it's easy to dismiss
the influence of an image
like this, to assume that
the photographer is just
another silent witness to an
atrocity like child labor,
and that policymakers can
easily turn a blind eye.
But there is proof
that a photo like this
can have a huge impact.
In developing nations
like Bangladesh,
child labor is a huge problem,
with around five million
children between the ages of
five and 14 currently employed.
Poverty is the
driving factor that
causes families to
send children to work
in hazardous and low
wage jobs, such as brick
chipping, construction,
and waste picking
instead of attending school.
In many nations, labor laws
exist to protect children,
but they're not often enforced.
In developed
nations like the US,
labor laws are strict to
ensure that children stay out
of the workforce.
However, this wasn't
always the case.
Lewis Wickes Hine
from Pennsylvania
was a photographer and
sociologist in the early 1900s.
Now, you may know his work.
He took the iconic
photos of the workers
who constructed the Empire
State Building in Manhattan, New
York.
But his first job was
documenting the child workforce
of America for the National
Child Labor Committee
during the Industrial
Revolution.
At the turn of the 20th
century, kids in America
could be found working in
factories, plantations,
and even coal mines.
Across the country,
children as young as four
were making glassware,
textiles, and cigars.
Children worked long
hours with minimal pay,
and the work was often extremely
dangerous and sometimes deadly.
Hine's work also put him in
danger, and by all accounts
he received several death
threats by factory police
and foremen, and that's
because at the time
using children in the
workforce was something that
happened behind closed doors.
But Hines continued, often
disguising himself, sometimes
as a fire inspector
or Bible salesman,
among others, just
to gain access
to the factories,
plantations, and mines.
It was Hines's photos that
brought the issue of child
labor to national attention.
Over the course of a decade, he
took thousands of photos that
documented the practice .
His work convinced and some
say shamed US lawmakers
to introduce new
industrial regulations
to protect children.
The photography of Lewis Hine
shows that images like these
assures that child
labor issues continue
to stay in the conscience of
those who can influence policy,
and for the photographers
who document child
labor all over the world, that's
the main motivation of the job.
As Bangladeshi photojournalist
and humanitarian
GMB Akash put it, "I knew
that as a photojournalist
that it was my duty
to tell the truth.
But besides that,
as a human being
I believe that it
was my moral duty
to find ways to alleviate
the pain of abuse and poverty
of those people in
my photographs."
If you liked this episode,
don't forget to subscribe.
It's the best way to
get new Seeker stories
episodes straight to you.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]